bonjour à tous bienvenue dans Parlement
Hebdo 45 minutes pour faire le tour
ensemble de l'actualité et parlementaire
de la semaine bonjour Michael et cette
semaine justement François Hollande a
assuré le service après-vente de son
pacte de responsabilité très attendue
par les syndicats le patronat mais aussi
les parlementaires qui attendent des
précisions sur les allègements de charge
et les contreparties le nom cumule des
mandats a été définitivement adopté
mercredi à l'Assemblée c'est la fin
d'une saga parlementaire entre les deux
chambres une loi décrié au Sénat mais
voté pas les députés le Conseil
constitutionnel est saisi il aura bien
entendu son mot à dire et enfin dans le
plus de l'hebdo nous nous pencherons sur
le rôle du président de la République la
Cinquième République et c'est monarques
c'est le titre d'un documentaire diffusé
dimanche sur Public Sénat
Jean Arthur et notre invité bonjour
jean-arthy bonjour sénateur
udi UC pour ceux qui ne comprennent pas
très bien ce que ça veut dire c'est le
centre sénateur donc
udi c'est depuis 1983 vous avez été
plusieurs fois ministre vous avez été
également président de la commission des
finances au Sénat spécialisé des
questions économiques on va bien sûr
développer toutes ces questions dans
notre émission mais c'est la tradition
dans cette émission le portrait est
dressé par vos collègues regardez
écoutez et quelques questions juste
après je sais quelqu'un de très
compétent dans les domaines financiers
et puis il avait une manière d'organiser
le travail de la commission qui était
très agréable respectueuse de la vie des
uns et des autres pour le schéma c'est
c'est naturellement une perte c'est
j'allais dire pour le Parlement européen
un acquis très fort d'avoir l'expérience
de Jean Arthuis son regard et son
expérience nationale mais son regard
européen c'est aussi un Européen
convaincu mais en européen d'exigence il
peut arriver qu'il y ait des textes que
nous soyons d'accord il y a des textes
sur lesquels nous sommes en désaccord
assez souvent mais le débat est
intéressant
genre
une fois qu'il a parlé c'est wattles je
veux dire vous avez rien à ajouter c'est
quelqu'un quand il parle de fiscalité
tout le monde comprend quand il parle
économie tout le monde comprend quand il
parle d'un sujet tout le monde comprend
il est pragmatique calme posé c'est mon
idole
alors John Arthur water
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
à l'atelier Goulet un sénateur comment
dirais-je hors norme très indépendante
d'esprit et qui n'est pas suspecte de
conformisme mais ce qui va étonné c'est
que au fond je me suis retrouvé sur le
blog de Public Sénat je vous inonde de
communiquer sur la gouvernance de la
zone euro sur l'équilibre des finances
publiques mais alors
là ça fait du buzz
et quand on vous dit spécialiste des
questions économiques ça peut paraître
peut-être un petit peu austère c'est ça
qui vous caractérise ou parce que genre
tu sais quelqu'un de différent c'est un
peu réducteur mais
je pense que la gouvernance politique a
trop souvent pris ses distances par
rapport aux exigences
parmi les mesures de ce projet de loi un
amendement socialiste a relancé les
débats sur l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse il supprime la notion de
détresse de la loi veille un amendement
qui a provoqué quelques dissensions au
sein de l'UMP Caroline motte
la France est-elle menacée par une
remise en cause de la loi Veil dans
l'hémicycle Najat Vallaud-Belkacem a
réaffirmé le libre choix des femmes à
disposer de leur corps elle prévient
aucun retour en arrière ne doit être
envisagé par l'opposition nous
combattrons évidemment sans relâche les
amendements rétrogrades qui sur un autre
banc de l'Assemblée vienne mettre fin au
remboursement par la Sécurité Sociale de
l'IVG au cœur de la polémique cessent
parlementaire UMP qui réclame le
déremboursement de l'IVG si la notion de
détresse est supprimée comme le prévoit
l'amendement socialiste
à faire là aussi porter dans le débat
public que c'est un problème qu'on ne
peut pas rester inactif devant le fait
que 200 000 femmes tous les ans recours
à l'avortement pour des raisons
d'ailleurs dont elles sont juges comme
législateur je dis nous avons un
problème législatif nous avons un
problème de santé publique un problème
social il faut régler ça sereinement
mais en vérité et ne pas rester dans le
déni c'est le sens de ces deux
amendements une position qui n'engage
pas le qui suscite de vivre réaction au
sein de l'opposition c'est initiative
individuelle qui ne correspond
absolument pas à la position du groupe
nous sommes parfaitement à l'aise sur la
loi veille on reste sur le cadre de
cette loi et ça ne pose aucun problème
pour nous non seulement nous l'assumons
mais nous leur revendiquons je le dis
j'ai été choqué par cet amendement de
des remboursements choqués en tant que
médecin en tant que député en tant que
citoyen les députés de l'UMP qui
s'engagent sur cette voie s’engage
exactement sur les traces du Front
national les Francis évidemment une
ligne rouge que nous à l'UDI nous
n'accepterons pas les débats sur ses
amendements devraient reprendre dès ce
soir alors Jean Arthur le projet de loi
a été voté la notion de détresse
supprimée est-ce que c'est une avancée
sociale
très franchement je crois que nous
sommes dans dans la rhétorique parce que
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse a
toujours été vécu comme Abraham par les
femmes qui ont vu recours et la loi de
Madame veille 74
avait indiqué que c'était en situation
de détresse que les femmes étaient
fondées à recourir à l'IVG c'est pour
cette raison que la loi était patient à
l'époque avec cette notion de détresse
sans doute qu'il fallait il faut bien
voir dans quel situation nous étions en
il est très vives réaction bon je crois
que cette loi est un progrès il a mis
fin à une hypocrisie insupportable et
la pratique faisait abstraction à cette
référence de détresse donc on a enflammé
le Parlement une fois de plus certains
disent qu'on ravive les tensions nées du
mariage pour tous est-ce que vous
partagez cet avis ou pas je pense que
vraiment
c'est une sorte de diversion qu'utilise
le gouvernement
alors que nous avons d'autres projets
majeurs sur lesquels nous devrions nous
concentrer François Fillon dit une faute
morale et politique vous partez sur ma
vie
à mon avis c'était inopportun de créer
ces crispations du corps social et de
donner une image du Parlement
qui est incompréhensible finalement
cette loi a égalité femme homme est-ce
qu'elle est assez ambitieuse
je pense que les lois ne règle pas tous
les problèmes trop souvent on a recours
à la loi pour une communication et on
multiplie les lois qui sont des
incantations des lois qui sont des
moments d'annonce on caresse l'opinion à
un moment donné et on affiche très vite
l'impuissance politique parce que ces
lois sont trop nombreuses bien souvent
inapplicables
les magistrats ne savent pas comment
s'en saisir pour les faire respecter je
pense que nous avons nous nous devrions
revenir nous devrions
rédiger les lois d'une main fébrile
comme le suggérer Montesquieu au moment
où ce texte était débattu à l'Assemblée
bien Jean-Marc Ayrault lui recevait les
parlementaires pour leur présenter ses
vœux et en même temps évidemment parler
de la situation de la France on va
écouter le Premier ministre
le constat c'est que la France est
aujourd'hui en passe de s'en sortir
elle est officiellement sortie de la
récession après cinq années de
croissance 0 en moyenne qui nous fait
retrouver à peine aujourd'hui le niveau
de richesse du pays de 2008 nous
prouvons qu'on peut être rigoureux dans
la gestion publique et en même temps
volontariste dès qu'il s'agit du progrès
social nous prouvons que notre pays peut
se réformer dans le dialogue y compris
sur des sujets sensibles comme les
retraites et sans trahir ce qui fait son
modèle et ses valeurs
laissez la conception sociale démocrate
que j'assume totalement et depuis
longtemps est-ce que vous partagez
l'optimisme du Premier ministre on va
s'en sortir je pense qu'on va s'en
sortir à la veille
de l'élection présidentielle de 2012
j'avais publié un livre avec Michel
Sapin et le titre c'était la France peut
s'en sortir mais les chemins suggérés
par sapin et par moi-même était quelque
peu contrasté alors je sais que il y a
du changement
de la République a donné un cap nouveau
il assume
social-démocrate proche peut-être de
votre philosophie c'est assez proche de
ma philosophie je suis pour l'économie
sociale de marché je suis profondément
européen j'ai vu que tout à l'heure
Gérard archer avec quelques peu anticipé
sur ce qui pourrait se passer dans les
dans les semaines qui viennent
maintenant j'attends
dans la rhétorique est-ce que la France
est vraiment sur la voie des réformes va
se réformer
des si proche des réformes que le pays
c'est beaucoup fragilisé que nous sommes
à la limite en risque d'implosion comme
si le tissu économique était sur le
point de se déchirer parce que depuis
des décennies nous avons été incapables
de l'adapter la mondialisation est venue
avec la modernité des moyens de
transport et de déplacement et puis avec
la numérisation elle est là la
globalisation alors on a désiré les bons
éléments c'est-à-dire que on veut
consommer à bon marché donc on va verser
course en Chine ou ailleurs mais on
maintient des standards sociaux des lois
sociales des prélèvements obligatoires
on taxe la production et on organise en
quelque sorte la délocalisation des
activités et des emplois on a mis en
opposition
les consommateurs et les producteurs les
consommateurs et les salariés qui
produisent
il va falloir surmonter et cette
contradiction est
réconciliée consommateur et producteurs
alors justement en janvier c'est le mois
du marathon des vœux cette semaine
François Hollande s'adressait aux
acteurs de l'entreprise et de l'emploi
mais aussi au parlementaire
très attendu par le patronat et les
syndicats le patronatic s'interroge sur
l'ampleur réel des allègements de charge
promis tout comme les syndicats qui
attendent des contreparties importantes
en termes de création d'emplois Nathalie
Guillois
le seul qui vaille
le seul qui nous engage le seul qui
compte c'est l'emploi
encore l'emploi toujours l'emploi les
mots sont lâchés contre le chômage
François Hollande sort son arme le pacte
de responsabilité face à un public
composé de syndicats et du patronat le
président de la République cherche le
consensus le pacte de responsabilité
c'est un grand compromis social
qui obligera chacun à prendre des
engagements et en tout premier l'État ne
pas perdre de temps aller vite 4
chantiers aujourd'hui sont ouverts celui
de la baisse des prélèvements pesant sur
le travail de la fiscalité des
entreprises de la simplification
administrative et des contreparties
demandées aux entreprises en insistant
sur ce dernier chantier François
Hollande compte sur le soutien de tous
mais à la sortie les réactions sont
diverses ça reste complètement fou flou
sur la fiscalité et la baisse des
charges et des taxes sur les entreprises
et donc on reste assez flou sur la
baisse des dépenses publiques ce pacte
de responsabilité qui est proposé qui
est compliqué parce que la période est
compliquée il faut savoir si chacun est
prêt à assumer ses responsabilités la
CFDT est prête à le faire elle ne le
fera pas si le patronat ne le fait pas
il y a des engagements ferme pour les
entreprises les contreparties en termes
d'emploi je le confirme que je n'y crois
pas baisse des charges contre emploi les
négociations sont lancées des
négociations qui aboutiront à une grande
conférence économique et sociale au
printemps
est-ce que vous partagez la vie des
syndicats se pacte et floues
c'est formidable tout ce qu'on a fait
depuis 18 mois
il faut dire renoncer car ces
manifestement tu n'as pas et donc le
gouvernement se cale sur des
propositions que nous n'avons cessé de
faire
alors
à ce stade là c'est très bien mais
réduire les déficit ça ne peut pas
passer par l'augmentation des impôts sur
le ras-le-bol fiscal on arrête et
d'ailleurs je lui parle d'augmenter le
barème pour que le produit fiscal
progresse on se rend bien compte
il faut réduire la dépense publique
excellent et qu'est-ce qu'on fait
j'entends des propositions
qui sont d'une extrême banalité ça fait
20 ans concernant les régions les
départements
dans la dépense publique il y a quoi il
y a les salaires des fonctionnaires les
charges sociales correspondantes au
salaire des fonctionnaires il y a le
paiement des retraites des
fonctionnaires donc considérable il y a
les dépenses de guichet la location
qu'est-ce que vous proposez
qu'on revoit
la durée du temps de travail dans les
trois fonctions publiques et chez les
opérateurs de l'État et des départements
c'est l'association qui relèvent du
secteur social l'unionops 750
000 personnes dont les dépenses sont
couvertes le temps de travail c'est ce
que vous proposez absolument à mon avis
oui plus qu'on allait rechercher dans
les régions les départements X Y mais il
faudra également aller chercher dans les
régions et les départements on a vécu
la pratique la gestion publique c'était
sous
la protection de l'État-providence et on
est allé jusqu'au bout de
l'État-providence pour constater qu'il
était aujourd'hui en faillite est un
Providence qu'il est rangé par les
corporatismes corporatisme des
fonctionnaires des politiques du
politique François Hollande dit faire
preuve de responsabilité ça engage tous
les politiques est-ce que par hasard si
jamais il y avait un texte vous voteriez
comme le propos Jean-Pierre Raffarin qui
dit et pourquoi pas le voter ce qu'on a
fait jusqu'à maintenant était d'une
confusion extrême y compris la
décentralisation parce que on n'a pas
on n'a pas déterminé clairement les
compétences exercées par les communes
les communautés de communes les
départements et les régions
alors le millefeuille le problème n'est
pas là le problème c'est de savoir qui
fait quoi je trouve que au plan
démocratique il n'est pas supportable
que le citoyen soit à ce point dans
l'interrogation qui fait quoi dans les
services publics que l'on soit à ce
point encadré par des normes tous
azimuts des corsets partout on parle
d'innovation sans cesse mais pourquoi
voulez-vous que l'innovation
et à s'appliquer uniquement dans la
sphère marchande pourquoi ne pas innover
dans la réponse aux attentes de nos
concitoyens réponse de services publics
j'attends qu'on nous donne ces marges de
liberté et que l'on soit responsable que
l'on rencontre et à mon avis le meilleur
levier de la réforme des collectivités
territoriales ne sera pas la loi portant
réforme on en a fait d'État qui ne
marche pas le vrai levier c'est la
réduction des crédits que l'État versera
au collectivité territoriales voilà une
des propositions cette fois on va parler
des sénateurs et des députés vous savez
que le loi sur la loi sur le non cumul
des mandats a été voté
c'est une véritable saga le nom cumul et
des mandats une promesse de François
Hollande votée à l'Assemblée puis rejeté
au Sénat avant d'être définitivement
adopté par les députés retour sur ces
rebondissements avec Jean-Baptiste
Daoulas
épreuve de patience pour Manuel Valls
les sénateurs ont tout fait pour
échapper au nom cumul en septembre 2013
le Sénat vote la fin du cumul des
mandats mais seulement pour les députés
les radicaux de gauche et quelques
socialistes ont fait bloc avec l'UMP le
ministre de l'Intérieur est irrité le
texte sera adopté Infiné par
alors vous avez raison c'est un
pronostic que je fais retour à
l'Assemblée pour une deuxième lecture en
novembre les députés ont rétabli
l'interdiction du cumul pour les
sénateurs Manuel Valls retourne au Sénat
la semaine dernière mais sans grand
espoir comprendrait que le gouvernement
défende le corps même de son texte de
loi à travers cette amendement mais
l'opposition et les Radicaux de Gauche
torpilles à nouveau le texte outre une
opération de communication laissant
croire qu'on lave plus blanc sans rien
laver ce projet vise d'abord à
substituer des parachutistes au cumulard
en remplaçant des parlementaires élus
grâce à le racisme local personnel par
des parlementaires entièrement
dépendants des parties auxquelles ils
appartiennent pour l'adoption 184 contre
118 le Sénat a adopté le Sénat a encore
vider le texte de sa substance ce sera
donc à l'Assemblée nationale de
tranchées le vote est prévu demain mais
l'UMP espère bien que le texte ne sera
jamais appliqué c'est une question de
volonté politique en cas de retour au
pouvoir l'UMP promet d'abrocher le texte
avant même qu'il ne s'applique Christian
Jacob utilise cette commodité de langage
il sait très bien qu'il y aura pas de
retour sur le cumul des mandats parce
que la société souhaite que les élus ne
cumulent plus elles souhaitent la
modernisation de la vie politique malgré
le vote de demain le feuilleton du cumul
n'est peut-être pas terminé
alors est-ce qu'il est terminé ou pas ce
feuilleton du cumul est-ce que c'est
réaliste de vouloir saisir le Conseil
constitutionnel mais d'abord je pense
qu'on devrait s'interroger sur les
compétences que l'on exerce aux
différents niveaux
d'administrations de l'état des régions
des départements j'observe par exemple
que pour les départements avant que
d'avoir redéfini les missions des
départements le gouvernement nous a
demandé de modifier le mode d'élection
des assemblées départementales c'est
vraiment mettre en a charrue devant les
boeufs et s'agissant du Parlement
d'abord je veux dire que les ceux qui
cumulent des mandats un mandat local et
Amanda national ne sont pas forcément
les moins présents dans le travail
parlementaire par ailleurs il y a le
problème du cumul qui est des questions
une activité professionnelle et un
engagement au sein du Parlement je pense
qu'on va vers la suppression des cumuls
de mandat mais alors pourquoi ne pas
réduire
de de moitié le nombre des
parlementaires a-t-on besoin d'autant de
sénateurs et d'autant de députés je ne
crois pas
je trouve que le gouvernement n'est pas
cohérent on fait des réformes pour
accréditer qu'on fait quelque chose et
on sait pas très bien à quelle finalité
on opère vous le sénateur est-ce que
vous avez l'impression à force de
vouloir rester sur cette loi de vouloir
garder ce cumul pour un sénateur et un
mandat local est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que le Sénat là a manqué un
tournant de l'histoire ou pas je pense
que on est en marche du courant
d'opinion parce que l'opinion est assez
critique à l'égard de tous ceux qui sont
supposés exercés des prérogatives
publiques du pouvoir
il y a un vrai sujet qui la gouvernance
du Sénat nous voyons bien que il
faudrait rapprocher les points de vue
sortir des tranchées si le Sénat veut
être le clone de l'Assemblée alors qu'il
n'y a pas l'obligation du fait
majoritaire
on n'aura pas besoin du Sénat le
Seigneur devrait être le lieu où
l'échange politique se calme s'apaise et
que dans ces conditions que l'on soit de
gauche de droite ou du centre on puisse
convenir d'un certain nombre de réformes
indispensables pour la société préparer
ses coalitions dont nous avons besoin
nous sommes à l'heure de la
mondialisation et nous continuons à
entretenir un combat stupide stérile la
gauche et la droite depuis des années
s'oppose moyen dans quoi lorsque l'un
d'entre nous fait une avancée pour
un projet positif il faut du courage
immédiatement il est sous la sous la
mitraille de son propre camp et éduquant
adverse et voilà comment on tire tout le
monde vers le bas comment on explique
pas aux Français la nécessité et
l'urgence des réformes les logiciels
devraient faire cela et j'en veux au
président bel et à la gouvernance
majoritairement de gauche du Sénat de ne
pas avoir institué é ce mode de
fonctionnement nous continuons à voter
n'importe quoi il y a pas de cohérence
entre les différents textes qui viennent
en discussion on est là dans une espèce
d'immense atelier où chacun bricole son
petit bout de texte à sa convenance mais
quelle logique quel message voulons-nous
délivrer quelle vision
on va aller politique envers les
institutions et même envers les médias
c'est un sondage qu'il le dit et c'est
notre zoom de la semaine
et pour ce jour nous accueillons Thomas
Guénolé bonjour bonjour
il existe une grande défiance de la part
des Français en vert la classe politique
envers les médias envers les
institutions
simplement des Français favorables aux
partis politiques ça peut faire peur je
ne sais pas si à ce stade on peut encore
parler de défiance un moment il faut
arrêter de se cacher derrière son petit
doigt la population française à l'heure
où on parle vomi la classe politique
d'une part et la classe médiatique
d'autre part si vous regardez les
chiffres c'est sans appel on tourne à 75
80%. je dis bien la classe politique et
la classe médiatique dans leur ensemble
à ne pas
tous alors attendez juste oui bien sûr
pour bien comprendre ça n'empêche pas
qu'une que des électeurs disent mais mon
mère est très bien ou mais j'aime bien
tel journaliste il fait telsan analyses
que j'aime bien etc et j'ajouterai vous
avez des gens dans le même sondage qui
vous expliquent que à 80 % qui a trop
d'immigrés en France et qui vont vous
dire mais je connais tel type c'est un
immigré il est très bien il est bosseur
il pose aucun problème etc ce que je
veux dire c'est que il y a la vision que
vous avez sur l'ensemble de la catégorie
qui peut éventuellement être contraire à
ce que vous avez expérimenté
personnellement mais qui correspond à un
ressenti que vous avez sur le
fonctionnement de l'essentiel de la
catégorie professionnelle alors je
signale que à mon avis si on parle
spécifiquement la classe politique et de
la classe médiatique sur la classe
médiatique je dirais qu'il y a un manque
d'adéquation entre les sujets qui sont
traités et les sujets qui préoccupent
l'auditoire j'ai bien dit qu'il
préoccupe parce que ça peut être du
sensationnalisme et ils vont écouter
quand même on est d'accord
ça c'est quelque chose d'important à mon
avis ça c'est lié à la ça c'est lié au
fait que les médias sont de plus en plus
nombreux donc dans une concurrence de
plus en plus acharnée alors qu'il y a
une audience quelle que soit le support
qui se réduit de plus en plus donc il y
a mécaniquement une course
sensationnalisme c'est très difficile de
faire le sujet de fondez je pense que
le politique est confronté
à une sorte
d'impuissance par rapport au problème
majeur l'emploi
l'assainissement des finances publiques
la mondialisation alors
il va exister médiatiquement et il va
aller là où il y a de la lumière
et à 62 médias qui régulent en quelque
sorte la vie politique devient
l'émetteur en scène ils choisissent
parce que j'avais parlé de méthode qui
s'appelle la valse à quatre temps si je
peux me permettre exactement
sans arrêt les thèmes c'est ça et
l'homme politique me fait penser à cet
individu qui est dans une nuit noire
était sous un lampadaire et on se
demandait ce qu'il faisait là on lui dit
mais que faites-vous ici monsieur je
cherche mes clés de voiture mais
monsieur pensez-vous que vos clés sont
ici non mais c'est là qu'il y a de la
lumière et voilà comment les politiques
recherchent ceux qui ont mission
d'organiser la vie collective et de
rendre possible le changement pour que
chacun y trouve son compte son prix est
dans une dans une sorte des déviances et
on ne sait plus où est l'acteur où est
le miroir oui alors deux choses d'abord
sur ce que vous décrivez quand je vous
disiez il y a une course de
sensationniste la classe politique aussi
cours de plus en plus après ça vous avez
une multiplication des méthodes que moi
j'appelle la valse à quatre temps dans
un premier temps vous faites une
provocation de type quand même il y a un
vrai problème avec les Arabes dans ce
pays tout le monde hurbe dans la foulée
non mais ce n'est pas ce que j'ai dit
j'ai dit qu'il y a un problème
d'intégration de la diversité des
cultures et ensuite vous rendez compte
il y a un vrai problème avec le
politiquement correct dans ce pays on ne
peut plus rien dire et vous terminez en
disant vous vous souvenez j'ai été le
premier à parler des problèmes de
tension culturelle dans ce pays Nicolas
Sarkozy a fait ça sur le karcher dans
les banlieues
Manuel Valls a fait ça récemment sur les
Roms etc etc ils le font tous de plus en
plus on assiste en fait à une
hystérisation du débat public faut pas
s'étonner derrière si la politique et la
classe médiatique ensuite ne sont plus
pris au sérieux c'est quand même un truc
très rapidement Thomas Guénolé ce que
vous nous dites par là aussi c'est
peut-être que les hommes politiques
n'ont pas pris la mesure du mal-être des
Français je pense en fait que il y a un
problème fondamental dont la classe
politique ne se rend pas compte à mon
avis dans son écrasante majorité c'est
qu'elle fonctionne en vase clos je vais
pas je veux pas dire ça en tarte à la
crème oui ils sont coupés du peuple etc
non non c'est que physiquement dans leur
vie professionnelle il fonctionne avec
des relais d'opinions qui sont en fait
de le Beast ils sont de réunions en
réunion et de réunion en conférence et
de conférence en débat table ronde et
donc leur contact direct avec la
population est assez rare parce qu'ils
sont dans une sorte d'écosystème fermé
et donc c'est très difficile pour un
homme politique quand bien même il le
voudrait d'être au courant de ce qui se
passe
et que le cumul des mandats pouvait
avoir un intérêt moi par exemple je suis
président de conseil général et comme
tel je me préoccupe de la petite enfance
et de l'accueil de la petite enfance et
j'ai cru de voir différé pour organiser
l'accueil par des assistantes
maternelles qui plutôt que d'accueillir
à leur domicile les enfants qui leur
sont confiés se réunissent à trois ou
quatre en un lieu extérieur et ça c'est
l'innovation de service public j'ai eu
les pires difficultés pour y arriver
mais si je n'avais pas été président de
conseil général jamais je n'aurais eu
l'opiniâtreté pour faire aboutir vos
projets
lu un rapport au lieu d'avoir
l'expérience par exemple on crée un
groupe de réforme fiscales en divisant
fiscalité des ménages fiscalité des
entreprises c'est absurde car la
fiscalité l'impôt est toujours payé par
les ménages merci Thomas guinolet
justement dans 2 mois se tiendront les
élections municipales les investitures
étaient à l'ordre du jour de l'UMP
c'était jeudi
une convention sur les municipales
étaient organisée au siège du parti la
droite s'est mis en ordre de bataille
avant les échéances électorales du mois
de mars une charte avec 6 engagements a
été remise à tous les candidats l'accent
est mis sur la fiscalité mais la
campagne est aussi axée sur la politique
du gouvernement Thibault Le Floch
nationaliser un scrutin local c'est le
pari de Jean-François Copé pour ses
municipales il ne cesse de le répéter
chaque bulletin UMP qui sera glissé dans
l’urne sera un vote contre la politique
du président de la République c'est la
seule manière de faire changer François
Hollande de politique c'est la seule
c'est qu'il subisse un désaveu massif du
peuple français l'occasion de ces
élections municipales le principal thème
de campagne pollump ce sera la fiscalité
et le trop-plein d'impôts les Français
disent que le niveau de la fiscalité il
faudrait quelque chose d'essentiel les
Français subissent depuis maintenant 18
mois un matraquage fiscal qui fait qu'il
n'en peuvent plus ils n'en peuvent plus
y compris sur le plan local dans une
charte publiée jeudi l'UMP s'engage
notamment à ne pas augmenter le taux des
impôts locaux et à réduire le train de
vie de leur commune le parti de droite
n'oublie pas non plus le champ
sécuritaire en proposant notamment
d'armer les policiers municipaux et
d'expulser les délinquants des logements
sociaux des propositions qui pourraient
séduire les électeurs tentés par un vote
Front national mais Jean-François Copé
reste inflexible sur la question des
alliances avec le parti d'extrême droite
toutes celles et ceux qui entre les deux
tours des élections municipales seraient
tentées pour grappiller quelques voies
supplémentaires de faire une alliance
localement comme on dit je ne sais quel
accord de retrait ou de regroupement
serait immédiatement exclu de notre
partie selon Jean-François Copé toutes
les conditions sont réunies pour que
l'UMP sorte vainqueur de ses municipales
avec un objectif faire basculer les
villes de plus de 9000 habitants à
droite alors que pour l'instant elles
sont majoritairement à gauche
alors tu es un sondage CSA a été publié
cette semaine dans LE FIGARO
46%
des intentions de vote pour les
municipales au centre et à droite est-ce
que finalement ce n'est pas dû à une
nationalisation du scrutin comme le dit
Jean-François Copé notamment il faut
nationaliser un impact de la politique
nationale on l'a bien vu au précédentes
consultations c'est redoutable d'être
candidat localement sous les couleurs du
parti au pouvoir
ceci a fait la réussite de la gauche aux
Indiens consultation
on ira-t-il le même cette fois-ci
c'est probable mais soyons conscients et
c'est ce que révélait les sondages que
monsieur ganolé nous rappelait c'est
qu'il y a une vraie exaspération au plan
national à l'égard de l'ensemble des
formations politiques en revanche au
plan local je pense qu'on porte d'abord
une attention
aux candidats alors personnalité à la
vision qu'ils expriment et à la méthode
qu'il propose pour rassembler les
citoyens autour de projets comment
construire l'avenir d'une commune d'une
communauté de communes vous êtes
désormais candidat aux élections
européennes
c'est parce que je pense qu'en matière
économique en matière financière
toute régulation infra-européenne est
une gesticulation c'est de la poudre aux
yeux national et que tout se passe au
niveau européen c'est que aujourd'hui ce
qu'on appelait les les prérogatives de
souveraineté
exercé au plan national
c'est de l'illusion
comment voulez-vous par exemple réguler
les flux migratoires autrement quand
mettons en commun ces souveraineté
comment voulez-vous lutter contre la
fraude fiscale contre les paradis
fiscaux comment voulez-vous
esquissez une défense crédible à
l'échelle de la mondialisation tous les
États qui ont encore des forces armées
réduisent leur crédit viendra un moment
où ils n'auront plus de
crédibilités municipales et vous
proposez une image une photo Jean-Louis
Borloo François Bayrou jusqu'où ça peut
fonctionner cette alliance bien je pense
que moi je fais partie de cette
alternative
que des forces politiques se rassemblent
moi je trouve ça formidable dans un
monde où chacun a tendance à s'enfermer
dans une chapelle à agnier l'autre on
voit bien qu'on en sortira quand se
rassemblant le pouvoir naît lorsque les
hommes se rassemblent ils disparaît
lorsqu'il se sépare
en appelant voter François Hollande
ça c'est un choix que j'ai pas partagé
mais je reconnais
que j'étais pas à moi non plus très
satisfait par la politique candide par
Nicolas Sarkozy je prends un exemple
hymen campagne en 2007 sur le thème de
la TVA sociale tu es courageux
la polémique se déchaîne entre les deux
tours des législatives qui suivent et on
va dire que la majorité nouvelle pour la
majorité confirmée perd 40 députés quand
vous perdez 40 députés c'est que vous
avez payé le prix et quand vous allez
payer le prix vous faites livré c'est le
genre de réforme qui ne peut pas voir
des failles médias il faut trois ou
quatre ans et donc ça se fait en début
de mandat et j'en ai voulu en effet à
Nicolas Sarkozy de ne pas avoir tiré les
conséquences de ses propositions vous
passez sur un tout autre sujet que vous
avez un téléphone portable j'imagine
comme tout le monde ou presque en tout
cas et bien l'Assemblée nationale ces
pensées je dis sur une proposition de
loi sur l'exposition aux ondes
électromagnétiques explication Jérémie
Hartman elles sont partout mes
invisibles les ondes électromagnétiques
font partie de notre quotidien mais
sont-elles nocives pour notre santé à ce
jour les études menées restent
contradictoires alors dans le doute la
députée écologiste Laurence abeille
propose une loi pour pour mieux encadrer
leur développement aujourd'hui nous
avons un texte qui dit qu'il faut
modérer l'exposition d'électromagnétique
que pour modérer cette exposition il y a
un certain nombre de dispositifs à
mettre en place d'abord le travail sur
ce qu'on appelle les points atypiques
les points atypiques ce sont ces zones
ou les ondes électromagnétiques
dépassent largement la moyenne
habituellement mesurée c'est le cas
notamment dans les sous-sols du métro
parisien avec la forte concentration de
téléphone mobile des voyageurs
l'objectif de la proposition de loi est
aussi de mieux informer les citoyens sur
l'implantation des antennes relais car
si une carte existe déjà sur le site de
l'Agence nationale des fréquences les
informations publiées restent très
techniques quand on n'est pas des
scientifiques c'est pas évident à
comprendre donc il manque voilà on
manque quand même d'informations et de
transparence le texte prévoit de limiter
et contrôler les sources d'émissions les
box internet devront obligatoirement
disposer d'un bouton marche-arrêt pour
la wifi et un pictogramme simple à
comprendre partout devra indiquer la
quantité d'onde émise par chaque
appareil qui en aimait la proposition de
loi interdit la publicité pour les
téléphones portables destinés aux
enfants de moins de 14 ans en revanche
la députée Laurence abeille n'a pas
réussi à imposer dans son texte
l'interdiction dans les écoles
maternelles d'équipement wifi qui sont
déjà prohibés dans les crèches et les
garderies
question très simple un peu
philosophique au nom du progrès est-ce
qu'on doit faire un peu la sourde
oreille sur tout ce qui est en train de
se passer
mais on est à la lisière des peurs
irrationnelles et donc je crois qu'il
faut faire confiance aux scientifiques
et
ce qu'il faut des lois partout
alors moi j'ai pas voté le principe de
précaution parce qu'une société qui vote
un principe de précaution est une
société qui commence à s'anestier à
s'endormir donc il va falloir que l'on
sorte notre aversion au risque peut-être
vigilant vigilant
bon et ne pas laisser les opérateurs qui
sont forcément suspects d'esprit
lucratif et de conquête de marché ce
qu'il faut c'est que les autorités
scientifiques qui éclaire le pays en
public et qui permettent à chacun
d'entre nous d'exercer sa vigilance
c'est la sensibilité aux ondes bon tout
abus peut-être nocif alors genre tu nous
allons passer à notre rubrique le plus
de l'hebdo la Cinquième République et
ces monarques c'est le titre d'un
documentaire diffusé sur Public Sénat
la Cinquième République française c'est
un système unique au monde qui s'appuie
sur l'élection du président suffrage
universel un président avec beaucoup de
pouvoir alors depuis 1958 cette
présidents se sont succédé sont-ils des
présidents monarques c'est l'objet d'un
documentaire diffusé dimanche sur Public
Sénat
le président de la République
homme providentiel leader charismatique
hyper président ou encore président
normal depuis la création de la
Cinquième République la légitimité et la
concentration des pouvoirs du chef de
l'État ont toujours suscité des
critiques il y a en France deux
institutions et deux seulement
issus du suffrage universel direct
national le président de la République
et l'Assemblée nationale alors qui gagne
le documentaire La Cinquième République
et ces monarques sur Public Sénat ce
week-end revient sur plus de 50 ans de
vie politique française la monarchie
républicaine à la française a-t-elle
fait son temps c'est la question posée
par la réalisatrice Michel Dominici les
intervenants journalistes universitaires
et politiques nous offre un bel exercice
de vulgarisation institutionnelle pour
certains la toute-puissance de la
fonction présidentielle est justifiée au
profit de la stabilité politique
le premier devoir des institutions c'est
de rendre le pays gouvernable
et donc la Cinquième République a voulu
renforcer le rôle de l'exécutif les
partisans d'une sixième république
pointe eux le décalage de notre région
avec l'évolution de la société tout le
monde sent que ces institutions sont
anormales tout le monde sent que cette
hors des palais nationaux est anormale
tout ça vient de ce présidentialisme qui
diffuse son irresponsabilité depuis le
sommet l'auteur du documentaire en
profite aussi pour bousculer certaines
idées reçues comme celle du concept de
l'hyper président
avec l'affaiblissement chronique des
États notamment dans le domaine
économique derrière nos institutions
c'est finalement le pouvoir politique en
lui-même qui est à redéfinir
alors Jean arty est-ce que la Cinquième
République relève d'une certaine
féodalité finalement avec son monarque à
sa tête en tout cas la captation du
pouvoir par le Président de la
République avec cette bipolarisation
tout dépend du président une fois qu'il
est élu on procède aux élections
législatives et c'est lui qui va donner
les investitures il se trouve avec une
majorité qui est quelque peu affaiodé et
donc le Parlement a les plus grandes
difficultés à exister on a l'impression
que tout est supervisé jusque dans le
moindre détail par le Président de la
République c'est insupportable la
Cinquième République a-t-elle fait son
temps finalement faut-il passer à la
il faut redonner du pouvoir au Parlement
et il faut être bien conscient par
ailleurs que ce pouvoir national devient
quelque peu dérisoire alors de la
globalisation et on voit bien que pour
retrouver les les États les puissants
européennes dominalement à la fin du 19e
à la veille de la guerre de 1914
et puis elles se sont deschirées et
aujourd'hui c'est puissances
encore la nostalgie de ce qu'elles
étaient je pense que l'avenir doit les
rassembler dans l'Union européenne et
c'est à ce moment-là qu'on retrouvera
une vraie puissance la rencontre d'un
homme et d'un peuple comme on disait à
l'époque oui à un moment donné mais
c'était une conjoncture particulière et
on voit bien qu'il y a un
dysfonctionnement de la gouvernance
publique dans ce pays
je pense qu'il faut redéfinir les rôles
respectifs du président de la République
du gouvernement de la majorité qui le
soutient à l'Assemblée nationale il faut
aussi qu'on puisse se préparer changer
alors sans doute un peu plus de
proportionnelle mais à mon avis on a un
trop grand nombre de parlementaires
et par ailleurs le président doit être
capable de faciliter des coalitions pour
des majorités suffisamment larges comme
le font d'autres pays européens
structurelles indispensables qu'on
n'arrête pas d'ajourner
un exemple de la lucidité et du courage
des propositions que vous faites
aujourd'hui genre merci d'avoir
participé à notre émission merci d'avoir
invité Marion on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine à bientôt bonne semaine
trois ans après la chute du président
Benali où en est la Tunisie instabilité